right the president's personal attorney
Michael Cohen says he will claim his
Fifth Amendment right not to answer
questions in the stormy Daniels lawsuit
the move allows Cohen to avoid
testifying about the deal to keep the
adult film actress from talking about an
alleged sexual encounter with mr. Trump
Jeff BA shows us how staying quite could
protect Cohen from a criminal
investigation Jeff good morning good
morning
it is the criminal case that Cohen is
most concerned about he's pleading the
fifth and attempting to delay court
proceedings in the stormy Daniel case
Daniels case any documents or sworn
testimony in that case can potentially
be used by federal prosecutors in the
criminal case it isn't uncommon for
someone facing both civil and criminal
cases to plead the fifth what is
uncommon is for a personal attorney to a
president to do it as for the criminal
case a federal judge in Manhattan today
is holding a hearing about the material
seized in the raids on Cohen's home
office and hotel room earlier this month
the judge will consider a request by
Cohen to appoint an outside lawyer to
review the evidence and potentially weed
out any material that's covered by
attorney-client privilege and that of
course is at the heart of that case we
know that President trumps lawyers
including Rudy Giuliani met with Special
Counsel Rob Muller yesterday does this
mean that they're closer to an interview
with the president well and that was the
topic of the conversation on Tuesday and
you and I talked about this last week
Giuliani was brought in to rekindle
those negotiations which seemed to break
down after that rate of Cohen's property
but now they've restarted of course the
negotiations continue and there are
those who think the president shouldn't
talk to Muller but obviously it's
something that Giuliani thinks that he
can resolve get these talks going quick
into well that's what he said that's
probably unrealistic I thought it was
interesting at Giuliani told that the
Wall Street Journal we're trying to
assess their good faith meaning with
special counsels good faith yeah
an early shot across the bow yeah what
what to see how that goes over with the
special counsel all right thank you Jeff